[Music]  everybody stay quiet stay quiet  this is crazy i remember you guys like  one and a half year you guys come here  if you remember we say  i said if allah won't i'm gonna become  ufc champion now we're here  we ufc champions and uh  you know it's like uh one week before  the biggest fight in ufc history  and you know if allah won't we're gonna  win this fight  you know when allah with you nobody can  stop him  [Applause]  no irish team no irish whiskey nobody  can say  no chicken this is impossible number one  important most important for us stay  connect with  god because without this like money  family  nothing give you like like like you have  connect with god you know like even  doesn't matter what happened with you  what's like  you always have to pray you always have  to stay humble and stay  focus and stay connected with god this  is very important for us  this is you ufc champion or not doesn't  matter  and i wanna say thank you so much guys  you know what you